all right get this governor andrew cuomo
still playing the role of a hero in his
own mind
more than a year after ordering six
covet patients sick covert patients back
into nursing homes contributing
to the second highest death toll in the
nation that according to a brand new
report get this
this week he ran a victory lap after 70
percent of new yorker adult new york
adults
received a vaccine dose lifting
restrictions then
on the entire state watch how we
celebrated
what new york has done is extraordinary
we went literally from worst to first
we're going to light all the state
assets
empire state building and blue and gold
and we're going to have fireworks really
uh we're out of ventilators we don't
need ventilators right
uh remember the nursing homes that
wasn't my idea and then he lied about
the numbers
and you remember the death toll 52 995
he says uh it wasn't his fault he got
the european virus
and the vaccine he said he didn't want
to use the vaccine because donald trump
came up with it
that certainly changed didn't it there
every step of the way
telling us about it and how she felt his
house republican conference chair
uh republican elise stefanik
congresswoman welcome or i said
chairwoman welcome back
your reaction to his celebration my
reaction is
andrew cuomo is the worst governor in
america and he said one thing that's
accurate is what new york has done
is extraordinary what it is is an
extraordinary
failure under governor cuomo's failed
leadership we've had the highest per
capita rates of death
we've lost over 15 thousand vulnerable
seniors
and we know that governor cuomo
committed federal crimes when he
covered up that number the toll of kovid
and what happened in our nursing homes
on top of this
he's facing multiple investigations both
from the new york state attorney general
and at the federal level
for these potential crimes he's also
facing numerous charges when it comes to
sexual harassment and sexual assault
against state employees so he is the
worst governor of america
no amount of fireworks paid by new york
taxpayers is going to cover that up
the new york people understand that they
have
he's been political about how he's led
during covid and he's pocketed
five million dollars on his book running
a victory lap
while not serving new yorkers and again
if you look at the death toll it's the
highest per capita in the nation
and his warring with our ridiculous
mayor didn't help things at all their
lack of communication coordination
really was
uh damaging let's move on and talk about
somebody that has a job i can't quite
figure out
he's climate czar and he's traveling the
world his name is john kerry
republicans have some questions what's
your question
my question is what is john kerry doing
is he doing this on the taxpayers
dollars
he was appointed by president biden to
serve as the special envoy
for climate issues and john kerry has
been flying around the world
having conversations and back channels
with the chinese communist party
having conversations with the iranians
sharing classified information that puts
israel in a very difficult position most
recently he was in egypt
he has a position that has a seat on the
national security council
this was not a senate confirmed position
so there's no
oversight that was done when he was
appointed to this so republicans want to
know
what is he actually doing is it funded
by the taxpayers because
the american people deserve transparency
we do not want john kerry
selling out america having conversations
with her adversaries around the world
right he wants to get a climate change
conference going uh and uh up and
running by november
uh he wants everyone ready he was in
egypt
i'm not sure why and i'm not sure who's
paying but i would love to get those
answers
next let's uh move on and talk about
something else that matters a lot and
that is
joe biden we know he doesn't like to
take uh go into a lot of unscripted
situations
but we're starting to learn more about
his script he was spotted we'll take a
look at this now
you zoom in on the cards he holds he's
overseas at the g7 nato summit then goes
to meet with vladimir
putin in geneva and his cards reveal
talking points anti-trump talking points
on the doj
does this surprise you that i thought
this domestic policy issue you think
he'd have
maybe some notes on nato it's history
and where it's going
or russia vladimir putin the people he's
killed no it's donald trump
yes unfortunately uh the biden
administration and president biden we
know he always needs staff prepared
talking points but what is really
disappointing is
on the international stage presidents
typically
leave political issues at the water's
edge we talk about
unif about unified american interest
abroad not attacking
republicans in joe biden's case so it
was very disappointing to see that
rather than again talking about
important issues like being tough on
russia
whether it's our support for ukraine to
counter putin's
rise in the region he instead decided to
bring talking points to attack
republicans that is not what the
international community should be
hearing
and that's not what we as elected
officials want to see from our president
and congressman lastly and possibly most
important the new york times has noticed
that republicans are legitimately
outraged and on the same page
when it comes to what's happening at the
border a chronic problem that's getting
worse
what sticks out that new york times
covered this story
well the new york times was so
frustrated that republicans are unified
in our message
of outlining the many crises that face
america today because of joe biden's
policies the border crisis the economic
crisis
the crisis of crime and more the new
york times actually wrote a hit piece
but what was amazing about the hit piece
brian is
they took the time to outline all of
these crises
that are impacting every american family
it means republicans are winning
we have momentum on our side and we're
talking about issues that matter to the
american people and we're holding
joe biden and nancy pelosi accountable
for their failed socialist policies
perfect segue to our next segment uh
congresswoman congratulations on your
pregnancy you kept it secret for quite a
long time as we mentioned in the break
that's why you're on the intelligence
committee uh because you can be trusted
with that but i know it's your first
child and it's got to be exciting
and you're still going 100 miles an hour
i really respect that congressman thanks
so much
thank you so much brian all right
meanwhile hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else